hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
neuen nicht lachen Challenge das ist das
Video auf das wir reagieren
man
okay ab jetzt ich lache gar nicht mehr
[Musik]
was ist denn das für ein Loch
es ist so dumm dass ich bei Sonnenschein
ne
einfach nicht witzig
[Musik]
Robert solche Experten gibt es immer im
Gym
[Musik]
no joke das einzige wo ich lache sind
diese extrem dummen anusuel means
oh mein Gott oh mein Gott
also warte mal
also ich weiß nicht wie sie da
noch laufen kann also
[Musik]
funktioniert
Katze
[Musik]
du kannst mir wirklich ein Toast
hinstellen was umfällt und ich lache
es gibt solche Experten in meinem gymne
jetzt kann ich
oh ist das Ratte
oh das ist ein Affe
Gott
warum warum also in diesem Clips hat in
Russland immer alles mit Gewalt zu tun
schon wieder Russen da tut sich wieder
irgendwer
tauchten der da ein
du hast das kann doch nichts werden safe
richtig Stange durch 100% man sieht das
schon vorher kommen oh mein Gott
[Musik]
nein nein nein nein der Ball ist auch
nein doch
[Musik]
meine einfach
was ist das denn oh
[Musik]
ich gucke aktuell Sonne Serie auf
Netflix wo es darum geht dass die so ein
basketball team begleiten wie die immer
besser werden und so das so eine halbe
Doku lässt chance you wenn ihr
Basketballfan seid schaut euch das alles
richtig geil
[Musik]
Spiel habe ich
am
[Musik]
kaufen
oh mein Gott ist der riesig auch boah
Bill Clinton
ich kann mir diesen ganzen
amerikanischen Münzen nicht so ganz
relaten schöne Spiegeleier
warum hat er
das habe ich gar nicht verstanden
[Musik]
oh nein kommt wahrscheinlich alles
direkt raus boah
ist das ein Schwein
[Musik]
Schwein wer nach einem Hund glaube ich
das erste Haustier was ich mir holen
würde so ein Hausschwein
[Musik]
oh lol
aber ich finde das eh schon mal crazy
wenn man sich so Sprayer Videos anguckt
wenn die dann so eine so eine Dose
nehmen und die so einmal durch die Luft
werfen und dann einfach irgendwie drauf
drücken den ich mir auch dass das
perfekt dann nach vorne rauskommt wir
kriegen die das immer hin
[Musik]
es ist so dumm es tut mir so leid
tschüss
[Musik]
und wie kann vor allem die Technik noch
laufen
[Musik]
aber no joke ich habe Sandra immer dafür
gehatet was Sie für eine Position
einnimmt in der sie am liebsten Schild
aber nehmt euch mal so ein Sofa was so
ca so hoch ist oder ist eigentlich egal
wie hoch genäht euch mit euren Knien auf
dem Boden und nur mit dem Bauch dann
quasi auf das Sofa das ist eine richtig
perfekte Position man fühlt sich so als
würde man kacken das hört sich richtig
oh jetzt gerade an
oh ich bin Katzen
komm jetzt hier nur noch Katzen oder was
ach nee guck mal
eine Skyline
ja natürlich
an der Schule nie sonst so ein School
fight ich habe noch nie eine Schlägerei
auf dem Pausenhof erlebt also ich war
bei uns ich habe auch aber kein Mobbing
an unserer Schule erlebt das war so ein
stinknormales Gymnasium oder so weil es
auch keine Kranke Schule oder sowas wann
stinkt normales Gymnasium aber uns gab
es sowas irgendwie nie no joke habt ihr
euch auch immer gewünscht dass eure
Schuhe so ein bisschen mehr amerikanisch
sind mit zu Schließfächern und mit
diesem kleinen Springbrunnen aus dem man
so trinken konnte mit seiner richtig
geilen Mensa und so
[Musik]
was ist das
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
die sind doch einfach immer perfekt
geschnitten oh nein die haben
Deutschlandflaggen drauf also wir machen
direkt weiter oh Gott was ist das jetzt
[Musik]
was ist denn das man sieht doch hier
auch was ist das ist es nicht Erdinger
Weißbier hier Werbung es ist irgend so
ein deutsches wird wahrscheinlich so
eine Stefan Raab Geschichte oder so komm
wir spielen mit Fahrrädern fußball ist
gar nichts nicht klappen ne Katze ja die
kommen die Macht wieder nur eine Katze
macht dir alles
schon wieder eine Katze komm wir machen
weiter
ekelhaft Katzen sind schlimm ne wir
beenden der Show das Video meine Damen
und ich bin Katzen so schrecklich
wirklich schreibe immer gerne in die
Kommentare seid ihr Team Hund oder
teamkatze
des heutigen Videos auch beenden meine
lieben Freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
lasst gerne einen Daumen hoch unter dem
Video hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen ich
gehe jetzt